bonjour à tous excusez-nous de ces
quelques minutes de retard donc je suis
Marielle m de la chambre de métier de
l'artisanat
je vous remercie de participer à la
cinquième édition de ma journée
découverte des métiers de l'artisanat
organisé par la Chambre de métiers de
l'artisanat en partenariat avec la
Faculté des Métiers le CFE du CFA
pendant du bâtiment et celui des
apprentis d'auteuils les cinq web
conférences que nous proposons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la Semaine
nationale de l'apprentissage sont
consacrés à l'orientation des jeunes
vers les métiers de l'automobile du goût
de la fleuristerie de la beauté et du
bâtiment métier qui font partie de la
grande famille de l'artisanat avant de
commencer notre web conférence
j'aimerais vous faire part de quelques
éléments de contexte aujourd'hui
l'artisanat français est un secteur qui
a le vent en poupe un million 830 000
entreprises artisanales ont été recensés
en juin 2022 aujourd'hui un créateur
d'entreprise sur 4 est un artisan ce qui
atteste de la dynamique du secteur
quête de sens valorisation du fabriqué
en France recherche d'épanouissement
professionnel et personnel toutes ces
valeurs poussent aussi bien les jeunes
que les personnes reconversion
professionnelle vers l'artisanat
véritablement porteur d'un nouveau
modèle économique la preuve 178 000
apprentis ont été formés dans
l'artisanat en 2021 un record inégalé
l'apprentissage fait partie intégrante
de l'ADN de l'artisanat sachez que la
formation par la voie de l'apprentissage
offre de belles opportunités d'avenir
puisque 80% des apprentis sont en emploi
dans les six mois qui suivent leur
formation l'apprentissage vous permet
également de devenir entrepreneur en
effet près de la moitié des dirigeants
actuels ont été eux-mêmes apprentis
voilà de quoi alimenter nos discussions
et surtout nous espérons que cet
événement suscitera d'évocation
place maintenant à la présentation des
filières du bâtiment et des métiers
d'art autour de la table je vais laisser
se présenter donc les apprentis qui nous
font l'honneur de me rejoindre
aujourd'hui et leur accompagnateur
bonjour je m'appelle Guillaume je suis
apprenti au CFA bottines-sur-orge je
suis en BTS Ted plus d'énergie domotique
merci
apprenti en BTS fête en première année
un Brétigny-sur-Orge
bonjour je suis beau goss je suis
apprenti au CFA de Brétigny-sur-Orge en
BTS
et Arnaud Langlois pédagogique au CFA de
Brétigny-sur-Orge et je vais vous
présenter les différents métiers du CFA
n'hésitez pas de votre côté à poser vos
questions sur le chat nous y répondrons
juste après cette conférence qui pour
votre information est enregistré
donc on va vous présenter
l'apprentissage dans un premier temps
donc l'apprentissage dans un centre de
formation donc pour apprenti le but
c'est vraiment de créer un partenariat
entre un jeune apprenti une entreprise
et un CFA pour découvrir et apprendre un
métier le gros avantage d'un centre de
formation c'est de pouvoir découvrir un
métier tout en continuant ses études
donc ça passe par différents métiers les
jeunes qui sont avec nous aujourd'hui
sont en cap mais on commence soit en BTS
pardon mais on commence à partir du cap
et on monte crescendo sur sur différents
sur différents métiers donc voilà on
vous prépare un métier on vous prépare
un diplôme bien évidemment
tout en gardant un cursus scolaire et la
découverte d'un métier
par le biais d'une entreprise et la
formation au centre de formation
on va vous présenter
France ça regroupe 7 CFA en
Île-de-France donc nous représente le
CFA de Brétigny mais on a les mêmes
entités sur sur les autres départements
de l'Île-de-France donc le CFA de
Brétigny
Brétigny-sur-Orge
regroupe aujourd'hui à différents
métiers
donc on va avoir en termes de métier en
concurrence entre le Cap et le BTS on va
avoir de métiers du bois un métier la
menuiserie on va avoir de la peinture
on va avoir de la métallerie toute la
partie fluide on va développer un petit
peu après
une plomberie sanitaire et thermique on
développera après
un métier un petit peu d'art donc le
staff staff et décoration
et l'électricité voilà les différents
métiers qu'on représente au sein du
centre de formation
alors on vous propose quelques quelques
questions un petit quiz on vous laisse
le temps d'y réfléchir donc combien de
métiers existe-t-il dans le secteur de
l'artisanat
5500 250
tout le monde répond 500
vous êtes optimiste il y a déjà beaucoup
de métiers mais on l'artisanat
représente 250 métiers ce qui est déjà
pas mal donc on va avoir les métiers du
bâtiment des services de la fabrication
et de l'alimentation
on vous propose maintenant de voir une
vidéo pour vous présenter le CFA donc du
bâtiment ainsi que les métiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez découvert la vidéo enfin les
vidéos des différents métiers là on va
détailler un petit peu plus nos
différents métiers donc on va commencer
par par le gros œuvre donc le gros œuvre
c'est une des parties les plus
importantes dans dans le BTP en termes
de construction
ce soit sur la fondation de d'immeubles
de mur de cloison ils vont très très
loin dans dans leur métier puisqu'on va
travailler aussi avec du bois on va
travailler aussi avec du plâtre pour
pouvoir construire ces différents ces
différents bâtiments
un métier très porteur aujourd'hui un
métier où on est obligé de travailler
forcément en équipe donc il faut avoir
l'esprit d'équipe travailler en commun
puisque on est sur des chantiers qui
aussi regroupe plusieurs corps de
métiers mais quand les maçons sont
présents on est sur sur des chantiers
assez lourds en termes de construction
donc faut bien évidemment travailler en
équipe pour pour pouvoir monter ces
projets là bien évidemment savoir
s'organiser être autonome et très
heureux c'est la base de tout métier
bien évidemment dans le bâtiment dans
les métiers manuels
le métier
finition peinture donc là on est sur de
la peinture décoration on n'est pas on
n'est pas sur un métier du bâtiment
extérieur sur du ravalement par exemple
on est vraiment sur du métier de de
finition et et d'art peinture décoration
donc renouvellement d'un appartement
d'une maison avec avec un une
minutie très importante alors tout
métier forcément doit être minutieux si
on revient sur les maçons on est obligé
de respecter les cotes et des choses
comme ça donc faut être minutieux dans
les prises de mesure sur la peinture on
a une petite touche un peu plus d'art
quand même
et d'application pour pour pouvoir
intervenir sur ces métiers là le métier
de la peinture c'est là où on retrouve
le plus de de
d'apprentifs féminine le métier du
bâtiment est pas forcément le métier le
plus féminin qu'on peut retrouver mais
ça commence à venir un peu plus et dans
différents métiers comme la peinture ou
le staff qu'on verra juste après on a de
plus en plus de d'apprentis féminine
donc le staff justement là qui est
vraiment un métier d'art lui à part
entière ou on est sur quelque chose d'un
peu plus précis et un peu moins connu le
métier d'art renouvellement
réhabilitation création de pièces
complète sur la restauration de
bâtiments restauration de de Château
donc là on va créer notre propre pièce
on va créer nos propres moules donc le
staff c'est
c'est
du décor principalement du décor réalisé
réalisé en plâtre chose qui pouvait se
faire éventuellement
à l'époque en marbre et autres
aujourd'hui on peut faire ça en plâtre
des moulures qui étaient faites
forcément à la main aujourd'hui on
reproduit des moules on crée des moules
donc un staffaire crée ses propres
pièces c'est vraiment un métier un
métier d'art et on peut être très très
loin à la seule limite c'est la
créativité
métier de la menuiserie donc métier du
bois on regroupe du CAP ou du BP pour le
pour la peinture chez nous au CFA de
Brétigny on a que le SEAB que le cap
pour le pour le métier du bois menuisier
on a décidé cap et des BP donc des
brevets professionnels
c'est pareil ça reste un métier un
métier un métier d'art aussi ou la
créativité est très très importante
voilà on est sur du menuisier fabricant
le menuisier installateur donc on va sur
la fabrication de petits mobiliers fait
à la main ça peut être le création de de
cuisine de gros meubles
d'entreprises d'entreprises
éventuellement on peut aussi aller dans
l'installation on est sur de la
menuiserie un menuiserie en bois
éventuellement ça peut faire partie
aussi du métier de menuisier
on a un point important sur sur le sur
le métier du bois bien évidemment
puisque aujourd'hui de plus en plus on
travaille avec la nouvelle technologie
donc il faut être bon en informatique un
logiciel en 3D toutes ces choses-là
puisqu'on intervient forcément sur la
création de pièces
modules en 3D pour pouvoir après
réaliser ces pièces là
métier de l'électricité c'est pareil on
intervient sur du CAP ou du BP donc là
on est plus sur du
de l'installation complète d'une maison
pourquoi pas d'un bâtiment complet
installation de toute la partie
électricité donc tout le réseau de
câblage tableau électrique prise
compteur etc donc toutes ces choses-là
sont très très importantes là on est
plus dans un métier d'art parce qu'on
crée rien entre guillemets on suit on
suit un plan là où c'est très très
important si elle respect des règles et
des sécurités puisqu'on intervient sur
l'électricité l'électricité reste
dangereux puisque c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne voit pas mais qui est
aujourd'hui malheureusement mortel donc
il faut faire très très attention
respecter les règles les normes
d'installation bien évidemment mais
protections protection de soi aussi sur
les métiers de l'électricité
métier du fluide qui est un pôle très
très important au sein du centre de btpc
à Brétigny ça représente quasiment la
moitié de nos apprentis donc différents
métiers des monteurs installateurs
sanitaires des monteurs installateurs
thermiques
donc du cap et du BP aussi et nos trois
jeunes qui sont avec nous aujourd'hui
sont en DTS donc eux sont beaucoup moins
axés pratiques mais plus bureau d'études
et vous en parleront peut-être un peu
plus que moi mais sur la partie voilà la
conception si on est sur du génie
climatique conception complète d'une
installation d'une chaufferie avec la
canalisation la diamètre des
canalisations le débit de de ma
chaudière et de mes moteurs donc ça
c'est plus sur du sur du BTS fin de BP
et début de BTS et sur la partie
installation sanitaire et installation
thermique on est sur c'est pareil dans
la chaufferie mais plus sur
l'intervention soudure création de
pièces
installation de radiateur
création d'une salle de bain ça peut
faire partie c'est là où on va avoir
plusieurs corps de métiers création
d'une salle de bain on va avoir des
menuisiers qui vont peut-être faire des
meubles mais derrière le il faut que le
la peinture
puisse être là il faut que
l'installateur sanitaire puisse être
présent on a l'électricité avec des
normes on n'est pas une prise de courant
à côté d'un point d'eau donc tous ces
métiers là forcément à un moment donné
sont censés se regrouper et travailler
en commun on peut pas passer avant que
telle technicien soit venu ou tel
intervenant soit venu donc c'est là où
forcément on est obligé de travailler
toujours en équipe et peu importe le
métier qu'on va faire même si sur ça
paraît un peu plus brut sur sur le gros
œuvre il faut être très très minutieux
sur la plomberie il faut être encore
plus minutieux le métier du bois aussi
donc tous ces métiers là aujourd'hui qui
pourraient paraître être un peu
pas très très c'est pas très très beau
on voit de voix de garage aujourd'hui se
développe énormément parce que c'est des
métiers de plus en plus porteur de plus
en plus minutieux on a des normes de
plus en plus strictes aujourd'hui quand
on conçoit un bâtiment on est obligé de
respecter tel ou telle norme donc
forcément en terme d'évolution du métier
on aura toujours besoin de ces
différents métiers là
métier de la métallerie c'est pareil un
métier de la métallerie on peut
assimiler ça aussi aujourd'hui à un
métier d'art mais tallerie ferronnerie
puisqu'on est sur de la menuiserie aussi
en aluminium pour pour des bâtiments
industriels on est sur la création de
pièces ça peut être création d'un
escalier complet ça peut être à des
pièces aujourd'hui en ferronnerie d'art
on est sur la ferronnerie d'art aussi
donc ça reste aujourd'hui quelque chose
de très précis on est sur très précis et
très rigoureux puisqu'on est quand même
sur des machines très très dangereuses
en fonction des matériaux qu'on utilise
on a quand même déjà des choses très
très lourdes des découpeurs plasma ou
des choses comme ça ou quand on commence
à souder des pièces forcément il faut
être il faut être rigoureux il faut
travailler aussi sur sur aujourd'hui des
logiciels 3D la conception de pièces
pour pouvoir réaliser aujourd'hui des
choses des choses très très importantes
en termes de création de pièces c'est
pareil on est sur sur aujourd'hui en
contact avec un architecte parce que
avec un décor à l'intérieur parce que
quelqu'un veut faire un escalier avec du
fer forgé avec des choses comme ça et on
est obligé de développer bien évidemment
nos compétences
alors vous voyez affiché donc également
un nouveau une petite question un
nouveau quiz quels sont les quatre
secteurs que recouvre l'artisanat
donc vous avez tous choisi la deuxième
solution bâtiment service fabrication
alimentation à raison effectivement les
métiers de l'artisanat recouvrent bien
ces quatre ces quatre secteurs donc le
bâtiment qui vous est présenté à
l'instant dans les services vous allez
vous avez des métiers comme le garagiste
la coiffure l'esthétique le taxi le VTC
fabrication tout ce qui part du matière
première pour un pour aller vers un
produit fini par exemple
fabriquer fabriquer des bijoux fabriqués
des jouets en bois tout ce qui permet la
fabrication et l'alimentation à
l'alimentation c'est tout ce que c'est
un boulanger pâtissier boucher deuxième
cuisinier
restaurateur
voilà
donc on va passer la parole à Cécile
pierre médiatrice de l'apprentissage qui
va vous donner trois conseils pour que
vous muniez à bien votre vie d'apprenti
si vous choisissez cette voie de
formation
voilà alors donc je suis Cécile guerrier
donc médiatrice de la princesse à la
Chambre des Métiers de l'Essonne donc en
gros j'interviens contre quand il y a
des petits soucis avec avec l'entreprise
entre l'entreprise et l'apprenti je vous
rassure tout de suite la plupart du
temps tout se passe très très bien
mais effectivement il y a des choses de
pas mon expérience qui reviennent assez
souvent et je me permets du coup de de
vous donner trois petits conseils on va
dire clé pour bien bien démarrer son
apprentissage
alors ce sont des points on va dire de
bon sens mais en même temps qui sont
essentiels à rappeler aussi donc le
petit 1 c'est montré sa motivation alors
ça englobe beaucoup de choses montrer sa
motivation comme par exemple arriver à
l'heure c'est tout bête mais
effectivement il faut vraiment vous
mettre dans la tête que quand on est en
contrat d'apprentissage vous faites
partie de l'entreprise donc faites vous
faites partie de mon équipe
et que vous êtes payé souvent ça fait la
différence donc chaque minute compte et
que du coup l'équipe ne va pas vous
attendre ainsi de suite donc tout ça ne
serait-ce que d'arriver à l'heure ce
sont des cessons ce sont des signes de
montrer sa motivation déjà déjà dans un
premier point autre chose aussi
ne pas hésiter aussi à redemander une
tâche si vous avez fini une première
tâche alors c'est vraiment je parle pour
vous parce que on s'adresse à des très
très jeunes donc effectivement
ne pas hésiter même si c'est compliqué
parce que on se doute bien que c'est pas
facile d'aller voir un adulte pour lui
demander une otage vous demandez comment
il faut faire comment comment il va le
prendre comment voilà de toute façon ça
ne vous sera jamais reproché de demander
une autre tâche si
la première est terminée plutôt que de
tourner en rond ne pas trop savoir quoi
faire ne pas savoir où vous mettre
ce sont des choses je me suis dit qui
montre aussi que vous avez envie de
faire et de et bien faire après vous
avez tout à fait le droit de vous
tromper et vous êtes là pour ça
mais effectivement ça montre en tout cas
une implication
le deuxième point et pas des moindres
c'est se passer de son téléphone
portable
donc ça
c'est un problème récurrent qui revient
surtout tous les conflits
malheureusement
je sais que c'est quelque chose de très
très dur
que on vous demande parce que tout
simplement en plus là du coup on
s'adresse à des troisième et donc vous
êtes juste mais avec c'est une troisième
main je pense je pense que c'est juste
évident
on n'est pas là à vous dire
vous n'avez pas le droit du tout du tout
mais en tout cas dans les dans les dans
les
dans les heures de travail effectivement
il faut pouvoir s'en passer et vous
pouvez reprendre votre téléphone
portable à la pause au même titre que à
l'école et ça sera le même la même chose
c'est pas parce que il y a personne
derrière vous comme à l'école que
effectivement il faut faire il faut
faire vraiment les mêmes choses avec le
portable donc l'étiquette les snapchat
pendant les heures de travail on évite
s'il vous plaît et ça sera et ça sera et
ça sera le mieux et puis quand vous
retrouvez vous retrouverez votre
téléphone portable à la pause vous aurez
plein de notifications et de messages et
ça c'est super pour la satisfaction
personnelle
vous verrez ensuite le troisième point
c'est le solliciter des échanges avec le
maître d'apprentissage alors ça ça
revient un petit peu
j'insiste aussi parce que effectivement
beaucoup de conflits arrivent aussi par
le manque de communication
n'est-ce pas les messieurs du bâtiment
[Rires]
du coup particulièrement
alors
des échanges avec le mettre
d'apprentissage surtout au début moi ce
que je conseille c'est effectivement
vraiment dès les premières semaines même
si vous êtes sur les 45 jours de période
d'essai on essaye tout de suite de se
mettre dans le bain et d'essayer de se
donner toutes les chances que ça
fonctionne c'est à dire par exemple vous
avez une semaine c'est vraiment un
exemple vous avez une semaine de cours
une semaine d'entreprise
à la fin de la semaine d'entreprise ce
qui est bien et ce qui fonctionne bien
encore une fois de mon expérience
c'est de faire un petit point le jeudi
ou le vendredi de 5 minutes encore une
fois je voilà on est vraiment dans le
concret et on n'est pas rêveur
effectivement le mettre d'apprentissage
il va pas avoir une demi-heure à vous
consacrer pratiquement toutes les
semaines pour faire un point mais si
c'est juste 5 minutes pour
éventuellement dire écoute là
effectivement qu'est-ce qui n'a pas été
qu'est-ce qu'il y a les points à quel
point est à améliorer et quel point quel
point quel point est presque acquis et
ça se passe très bien je pense que c'est
bien de pouvoir s'auto-évaluer et puis
de s'évaluer aussi avec son maître
d'apprentissage dès le début déjà ça va
instaurer un rapport de confiance avec
lui un rapport ou en gros il va pouvoir
vous dire les choses même quand ça va
pas même si c'est pas super agréable à
entendre bah il va il va se dire bon bah
s'il veut faire un point toutes les
sérieux toutes les semaines de 5 minutes
c'est que voilà il est capable
d'entendre que quand ça va pas il faut
qu'on se dise et ainsi de suite aussi
dans les deux sens c'est-à-dire que
l'apprenti a le droit de dire bah voilà
j'ai posé une question à telle personne
on ne m'a pas répondu je ne suis pas
sentie bien je me suis pas sentie à
l'aise ce sont des choses mine de rien
qui en fait se dire les choses même si
c'est 5 minutes encore une fois qui ne
vont pas laisser traîner et laisser
place à des malaises
et des conflits en fait qui vont générer
des des conflits beaucoup plus grands à
laisser à laisser les choses
laisser les choses se tasser comme ça
c'est pas une solution donc vraiment
dans le métier du bâtiment effectivement
je particulièrement parce que voilà je
pense aussi que c'est assez masculin
peut-être aussi mais bon voilà en tout
cas on va vraiment essayer de discuter
un petit peu non mais c'est vrai ils ont
du mal à peut-être à plus poser plus
poser certaines certains mots et ils ont
tendance à dire c'est pas méchant c'est
pas du tout c'est plus tendance à se
dire oui j'ai pas le temps en fait j'ai
pas le temps de me prendre la tête à
parler j'ai pas le temps de me ça je
l'entends régulièrement donc
effectivement ce sont des choses
qu'il faut
voilà il faut se donner toutes ces
chances là dès le départ vraiment je
vous encourage à le faire
voilà merci beaucoup Cécile de ces
précieux conseils on va poursuivre
effectivement donc sur des informations
concrètes sur comment vous informer donc
si vous êtes intéressé par un métier
donc du bâtiment au CFA de Brétigny
donc dans les événements à venir il y a
la soirée de l'orientation qui a lieu
mercredi 15 février donc de 15h30 à 18h
donc on peut rencontrer les mettre les
formateurs des différents métiers
discuter avec eux visiter les ateliers
pour pouvoir découvrir ce métier et la
journée portes ouvertes aussi qui est à
peu près le même qui est sur le même
principe qui est le samedi 25 mars de 9h
à 16h30 pour revenir sur sur les
différents métiers le métier du bâtiment
aujourd'hui est énormément porteur
un CFA pour bien recentrer les choses
CFA c'est un partenariat une
collaboration entre un centre de
formation l'apprenti ou le futur
apprenti et une entreprise donc bien
évidemment pour pouvoir intégrer le CFA
il faut trouver une entreprise et il
faut garder cette entreprise là
donc ce que ce que disait ma collègue
c'est voilà 45 jours de période de
période d'essai c'est là où il faut
montrer sa motivation et avant et tout
le long de la formation parce
qu'aujourd'hui trouver un employeur
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
forcément le plus facile quand on quand
on est jeune des marchés d'entreprise
qui est toujours à un métier du bâtiment
est toujours un peu un peu sous pression
et toujours
un peu à droite à gauche sur les
chantiers donc c'est pas forcément
l'endroit le plus facile pour rencontrer
nos futurs mettre d'apprentissage donc
c'est là c'est là où il faut montrer
toute la motivation
on peut avoir et forcément la garder
tout le long du centre de tout le long
de sa formation puisque
terme de formation aujourd'hui on
travaille en fonction des différents
médias du cap on peut aller jusqu'au BTS
donc vous pouvez rester dans la même
montre prise pendant 6 7 voire 8 donc
c'est là où c'est très très important de
montrer toute la motivation qu'on peut
avoir et la communication a aussi très
très importante sur justement ce fait là
de dire j'ai pas compris est-ce que vous
pouvez me réexpliquer
pour qu'on puisse découvrir
éventuellement
les problématiques qu'on peut avoir au
sein au sein d'une entreprise
répondre à vos questions donc n'hésitez
pas à mentionner toutes les questions
que vous pouvez avoir dans le chat pour
l'instant visiblement vous n'avez pas
particulièrement de questions n'hésitez
pas à le faire on va passer la parole à
nos jeunes apprentis qui nous ont fait
l'honneur d'être présent avec nous pour
déjà vous demander donc à chacun d'entre
vous qu'est-ce qui vous a amené en fait
à choisir ce métier là
le fait que ça soit Muel je puisse
travailler de mes mains et d'apprendre
tout en étant payé et voilà le côté
alternance un salaire et en même temps
du coup vous faites du travail et on est
payé bah ça me motive je me lève le
matin pour toucher les sous
prélèvement ce que on a une rémunération
et j'avais pas donné en place en classe
du coup il fallait que je sois mon
possible à l'école du coup je voulais
faire un
capuche dans le métier ce qui te plaît
c'est de bouger en fait
et la filière comment vous l'avez choisi
quand je fais des stages
moi c'est grâce au stage de 3e que j'ai
fait dans la plomberie ça m'avait
intéressé et je suis parti je suis parti
c'est le stage qui a été déclencheur
mais du coup quand tu as choisi ce stage
en plomberie tu avais quand même une
petite idée ou c'était la pure hasard
pas du tout comme ça
et donc du coup tous les trois je pense
que le côté alternance ça vous apprend
alors qu'il dit alternance effectivement
bah CFA puis entreprise en tout cas en
même temps c'est pas puis c'est en même
temps
du coup est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
comment comment vous avez trouvé
l'entreprise la fonction la première qui
a accepté quand elle démarche vous avez
fait tous les trois pour trouver votre
entreprise
[Musique]
deux entretiens et sur les deux j'en ai
préféré vendre les deux sociétés
et du coup est-ce que tu avais un CV une
lettre de motivation quelque chose
surtout il y a des motivation ce qui est
en 3e on va pas forcément
du coup j'avais fait un cv pour la forme
comme
d'accord mais l'aide de motivation aussi
quand même de motivation et après quand
je me suis présenté j'étais présentable
et j'étais
important de souligner c'est à dire le
côté quand je me suis présenté j'étais
habillée comme il faut
faire attention
et donc cette lettre de motivation et ce
CV quelqu'un t'a aidé à la faible
d'accord
très bien et moi j'ai démarché beaucoup
beaucoup d'entreprises une trentaine et
à la fin du coup bah j'ai j'ai été
accepté dans une entreprise j'ai fait un
entretien ça c'est bien passé
alors quand tu t'es démarché
concrètement ça s'est traduit par
comment tu vas téléphoner ou des
déplacements j'ai envoyé des CV de
motivation
un petit peu combiné tout ça
[Musique]
les 30 tu as envoyé en plus à 30 ou
est-ce que pour certaines c'était des
appels pour d'autres c'était à côté de
chez moi j'y allais en vélo
et donc sur ces 30 à décroché combien
d'entretiens je crois 5 c'est pas si mal
ok
j'ai choisi du coup ce qui me
correspondait le plus d'accord les 51 OK
et du coup j'ai choisi celle que je
voulais
donc du coup c'est en fait ce que ce que
je retiens quand même c'est que c'est
pas si évident bon hormis effectivement
par connaissance mais sinon c'est pas si
évident de décrocher l'entretien mais
une fois qu'on a l'entretien visiblement
les employeurs si on se présente
correctement évidemment avec une bonne
lettre de motivation et un CV on a
toutes les chances de pouvoir intégrer
l'entreprise donc ça c'est important
aussi il y a une offre et est-ce que le
si jamais il y a une difficulté
individuelle est-ce que le CFA peut
donner un petit coup de main du coup sur
la recherche d'employeur le CFA oui
accompagne accompagne toute l'année
pendant le pendant la recherche et même
après
l'intérêt en fait tout tout se recoupe
c'est la motivation je me présente avec
un motivé même si je connais pas le
métier aujourd'hui il est sorti de
sortie de troisième forcément on connaît
pas le métier alors ce métier là va
métier du bois me plaît je vais aller
voir ce que ça peut m'intéresser et
faire ma formation mais en fait le
cursus c'est ça c'est switch si je suis
motivé je vais forcément à un moment
donné de trouver un employeur
aujourd'hui on a une multitude
d'entreprises qui cherchent mais qui
cherche un apprenti pour lui apprendre
forcément le métier mais un apprenti
motivé aujourd'hui c'est là où
malheureusement des fois on a un échec
c'est parce que l'entreprise
l'entreprise auquel on démarre a une
mauvaise expérience avec un apprenti qui
n'a pas fini sa formation ou qui était
qui s'est démotivé à un moment donné
il suffit qu'on trouve au bon endroit au
bon moment qu'on soit motivé et
normalement ça match assez vite
d'accord justement après après sur ça et
puisque je disais voilà ça découle d'un
CAP aujourd'hui ça peut être si on est
sur le pôle du fluide on a différents
cap mais des gens qui font assez
sanitaire un cap thermique après un BP
un BTS c'est pareil sur sur le métier du
bois on a du cap du bébé ça reste dans
la même entreprise donc si on est motivé
on est au bon endroit en bon moment on
était présentable accompagné
éventuellement des parents etc avec un
peu d'expérience stage de 3e on peut
faire c'est 2 3 4 ans de formation dans
la même entreprise ce qui peut être très
débouché sur des CDI ça peut même
déboucher sur des CDI aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont issus de
l'apprentissage son embauché par une
entreprise plus tard crée leur
entreprise et ils reprennent les
apprentis donc c'est et je la boucle et
justement si nous reprennent des
apprentis c'est que normalement ils ont
été bien formés et qu'ils ont eu ils ont
pris goût à l'apprentissage parce que
disait Guillaume
voilà un apprentissage des pays on n'est
pas à l'école
je n'ai pas trop l'école on n'est plus à
l'école dans un centre de formation on
est salarié de l'entreprise payé par
l'entreprise donc le salaire dépend du
diplôme qu'on fait et de l'âge bien
évidemment mais on est ensemble de
formation néanmoins on est éducation
mais une grosse partie de l'activité peu
importe le métier une grosse partie de
l'activité c'est si on est sur un cap on
est sur entre 14 et 16 heures en
formation technique théorique ou
pratique mais on est sur la partie
technique et le reste sur l'enseignement
sur l'enseignement général je rebondis
justement sur effectivement les
rémunérations puisque il y a une
question qui les poser sur combien on
gagne en apprentissage ça dépend de
l'année
on n'a pas la même moyen de migration
entre un jeune qui est mineur et un
jeune qui est majeur n'est pas la même
rémunération non plus aujourd'hui c'est
un pourcentage du salaire minimum sur
lequel vous avez pas de charge le
salaire brut
reste mais on est sur un cap j'aurai pas
dire de bêtises on est dans la série
[Musique]
normalement la rémunération est la même
après on est sur sur 35 heures quand on
est mineur sur un contrat de 35 heures
analyser donc pour faire un peu plus
l'été on peut moins un peu moins l'hiver
éventuellement en fonction des
conditions météorologiques mais on est
sur on doit être entre 35 et 40% du SMIC
donc ça on
sur la première ou sur la deuxième année
sur un cap après après quand on arrive à
plus de 20 ans BTS on gagne un peu plus
forcément et le BTS on est entre à peu
près 1004 et 16
charges de bonne chance à 1600 euros
voilà tout son niveau
d'étages
jusqu'à 1600 euros
l'avantage après en BTS c'est que on est
majeur donc on n'est pas soumis aux 35
heures on peut faire un peu forcément la
[Musique]
rémunérations donc
on peut dire que parce que quelque part
pour l'entreprise c'est un peu un
mi-temps quand même parce que il y a une
partie en formation et ça fait un une
rémunération plutôt conséquente par
rapport au temps passé dans l'entreprise
pour travailler pour pour le centre de
formation sur un cap c'est 12 semaines
par an au centre de formation
[Musique]
très important quand même à faire sur
sur du Cap le premier niveau on est une
semaine sur trois une semaine une
semaine au centre une semaine au centre
de formation deux semaines en entreprise
une semaine
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions qui
sont qui sont posées
est-ce que alors
je profite de votre présence puisque
vous êtes déjà qui vous adressez à
d'autres jeunes
quels conseils vous pourriez donner à
des jeunes qui voudraient
débuter un apprentissage est-ce que
voilà qu'est-ce que vous pourriez leur
dire qui serait bien pour eux de faire
ou tenter
[Musique]
un peu plus
sollicité un stage il y a des stages
alors là pour le coup en chambre de
métier on propose des conventions qui
permet effectivement qui permettent aux
jeunes de faire 5 jours de stage alors
un entre un et cinq jours c'est vraiment
au choix de stage pendant les vacances
scolaires exclusivement pendant les
vacances scolaires parce que le reste du
temps vous êtes en cours donc c'est pas
possible à ce moment-là mais en plus du
stage de troisième qui lui est
obligatoire et qu'il peut permettre déjà
de découvrir un métier puisque c'est
comme ça que tu avais découvert
effectivement c'est aujourd'hui
donc sachez que c'est possible de faire
un essai après il faut trouver
effectivement une entreprise qui accepte
de vous accueillir mais bon ça coûte
rien à l'entreprise et souvent les
employeurs c'est assez rare qui
n'acceptent pas un jeune un peu motivé
qui veut découvrir le métier entre un
jour et cinq jours donc ça vaut la peine
effectivement alors pendant les vacances
du coup de se lever effectivement pour
aller dans
surtout aussi les vacances c'est pas
pareil
c'est comme un salarié c'est 5 semaines
de congé par an
de notre période de recrutement c'est à
partir de maintenant jusqu'à début
septembre au plus tard la formation
commence enfin les formations commencent
généralement début septembre mais quand
on est en menuiserie on fait de la
menuiserie on est dans une entreprise de
menuiserie pour certains jeunes qui
aujourd'hui voudraient avoir un métier
manuel mais qui cherche encore ce qu'il
est possible de faire c'est d'avoir un
CAP en deux ans donc en 24 mois on ouvre
des formations en 30 mois qui commence
au mois de mars
donc forcément ça reste aussi de
l'apprentissage qu'il faut trouver une
entreprise mais pour un jeune qui a qui
trouve une entreprise
tout corps de métier nous on va lui
proposer de mars à juin de découvrir
différents métiers donc ils seront dans
leur entreprise et c'est l'entreprise
qui fait qui fait je sais pas moi de la
menuiserie par exemple
mais on va lui faire un peu de
menuiserie au centre de formation il va
faire un peu de plomberie un peu
d'électricité pour découvrir aussi les
différents métiers et pourquoi pas ça
peut arriver à se dire bah en fait non
ce n'est pas la même chose qui
m'intéresse c'est la métallerie et en
septembre d'intégrer une nouvelle
entreprise en métal
parce que ce sont des choses qui
arrivent souvent
vous demandez très très jeune ce que
vous voulez faire plus tard c'est pas
simple
on essaye toujours d'adapter je sais que
j'ai un jeune qui aujourd'hui est en
menuiserie et qui veut faire de la
peinture ils finissent sa formation de
menuiserie première année la première
année et il va intégrer la deuxième
année de peinture on va adapter un peu
les cours pour qu'il puisse rattraper le
retard et on a les jeunes qui arrivent
là d'ici quelques semaines sur des CAP
30 mois qui vont voir multimédia
alors on a une question vous avez déjà
un petit peu
me semble-t-il mais à préciser du coup
combien d'heures hebdomadaires à une
heure doit effectivement en entreprise
maximum 35 heures 35 heures à mineur
légalement un mineur
après c'est très bien que sur des
chantiers on n'est pas à regarder ça
montre pas donc c'est très compliqué de
dire un employeur bah non il est 17h31
je m'en vais voilà c'est toujours un
échange avec une entreprise où j'ai fait
un peu plus d'heures aujourd'hui j'en
ferai peut-être un petit peu moins la
semaine prochaine où on a un chantier à
terminer on essaye toujours de
s'arranger alors on fait pas non plus
c'est pas le but il y en a mais ça reste
du bon sens ça reste du bon sens voilà
c'est aujourd'hui on a un chantier très
important il faut qu'on finisse à rendre
la fin de la semaine donc on va faire
une demi-heure par ci par là en plus et
puis la semaine prochaine on a un
chantier qui a peut-être un peu plus
long on va pouvoir se permettre de finir
rapidement un peu plus tôt mais au stand
de formation c'est 35 heures on ira pas
au-delà et en entreprise également c'est
aussi c'est aussi français
à quel âge on peut commencer
aujourd'hui voilà il faut on peut
commencer à une formation alors si on
commence la formation en septembre il
faut avoir il faut avoir 15 ans pour
pouvoir faire cette formation là pour
pouvoir rentrer en formation il faut au
minimum avoir 15 ans pour pouvoir
commencer l'apprentissage l'anniversaire
des 15 ans passés
et fin de troisième aussi ou pas
forcément pas forcément pas forcément la
fin de troisième mais quinze ans ça
c'est important 15 ans et demi
quel recours à l'apprenti si son
apprentissage en atelier se passe mal on
s'adresse plutôt à ceci
oui et puis avant ceci il y a plein de
choses effectivement on soit
effectivement
enfin je pense que avec moi
effectivement ce sera ça sera il y a
plein de choses il faut il faut en
parler à son référentiel
les formateurs sont là pour vous aider
pour vous écouter vous avez
vous avez une chargée aussi
[Musique]
qui qui s'occupe aussi de ça donc voilà
vous avez beaucoup d'interlocuteurs il y
a
la rupture à amiable il y a plein de
solutions il y a la médiation évidemment
donc là effectivement c'est là où
j'interviens mais avant d'arriver à une
médiation il y a quand même pas mal
d'étapes
voilà mais en tout cas il y a plein de
choses plein de choses plein de
solutions on essaye toujours d'éviter
que ça se passe mal alors pourquoi ça se
passe mal parce que l'entreprise est
peut-être un peu trop insistante sur les
horaires de travail je n'ai peut-être un
peu moins motivé on essaye toujours de
discuter en amont sachant que nous à
chaque fois que les jeunes reviennent au
centre de formation on garde une heure
avec l'ensemble de la classe pour
discuter de ce qu'ils ont fait la
semaine en entreprise comment ça s'est
passé on a un carnet de vis qu'on
appelle un carnet de liaison entre le
jeune entreprise et le CFA donc c'est
une entreprise veut nous laisser un
petit genre de mail
cette semaine ça s'est pas bien passé
parce que si parce que ça on appelle les
entreprises on communique le plus le
plus possible et puis malheureusement si
à un moment donné on est à la rupture en
fonction de l'investissement du jeûne de
la motivation etc on peut accompagner le
jeune à trouver une nouvelle entreprise
et même le garder pendant quelques temps
sans entreprise
qui puisse continuer la formation
et puis dans la globalité de les CFA
qu'on vous a présenté aujourd'hui
ce sont des CFA qui sont très
sérieux dans le suivi dans le suivi de
leur apprenti et on laisse jamais
personne dans une situation compliquée
donc on saura toujours toujours quoi
faire
voilà ça on tourne on tourne en rond sur
la même chose à partir du moment où on
est motivé qu'on montre qu'on a envie
que c'est le métier qui nous plaît
malheureusement on n'est peut-être pas
tombé dans la bonne entreprise à ce
moment-là mais si on a envie voilà on va
on va on va vous aider à rebondir à
retrouver notre entreprise à vous
accompagner
on est là pour on est là pour les jeunes
pour leur formation
si eux nous
renvoie la balle en disant j'ai envie de
on trouvera toujours une solution
on retient un prévention d'abord et ça
commence par faire les points réguliers
là
ça évite d'avoir une situation qui
pourrait s'organiser mais c'est pas
toujours facile sans la personnalité de
votre personnalité à vous déjà et puis
de ces jeunesse
parce que il faut savoir oser
on vous laisse pas en tout cas dans les
CFA tomber non non laisse pas tomber et
puis enfin le plus important c'est le
dialogue en entreprise
et voilà en fin de semaine qu'est-ce que
comment ça s'est passé est-ce que j'ai
bien travaillé ce que j'ai des choses à
apprendre ce que j'ai des choses à
revoir à tous ces éléments là sont très
importants de pouvoir discuter avec dans
une entreprise on a forcément
un responsable
on a un maître d'apprentissage avec qui
on doit travailler en binôme assez
régulièrement et c'est avec lui qu'il
faut discuter justement pour éviter
d'arriver à
beaucoup plus difficile et c'est pour ça
voilà ce
ces trois points étaient importants à
rappeler alors il y a une question qui
s'adresse qui s'adresse à vous alors
vous y avez déjà répondu mais peut-être
qu'ils aimeraient que vous développiez
un petit peu je pense puisque en fait
c'est pourquoi vous avez choisi ce
métier
c'est la question qui vous a déjà été
posée clairement vous y avez répondu
brièvement mais peut-être que on peut
aller un petit peu plus loin dans la
réponse qu'est-ce qui vous a fait
choisir ce métier là plutôt qu'un autre
en fait
j'ai pris l'habitude j'ai appris ce
métier et vous êtes hors du temps ça m'a
plu ça m'occupe de plus en plus et
sur les salaires et tout ça ce qui
saigne aussi un petit peu voilà
même le fait que
on a sur les contrats c'est 8h17 heures
mais des fois on peut finir plus tôt
comme on peut venir plus tard ça
dépendra plutôt
[Musique]
au départ c'était le hasard et puis
après comme ça se passe bien les
horaires le métier lui-même j'imagine
aussi l'intérêt du métier
et les débouchés
de ton côté du coup de mon côté moi j'ai
choisi ça parce que c'était rémunéré
c'était manuel j'ai commencé par un cap
un serviteur sanitaire
[Musique]
je suis passé du chantier au bureau
actuellement et c'est
tu préfères quoi
chaque chaque
variante ses avantages et
en fait du coup
c'est un bureau d'études là aujourd'hui
on peut dire ça
c'est moins physique
quand il fait chaud dehors il y a la
clim quand il fait froid dehors il y a
le chauffage
ça c'est ça c'est pas mal et bah on fait
plus d'heures c'est plus psychologique
quand on est sur chantier du coup c'est
quoi qui est sympa
il y a une bonne entente le travail
d'intéressant il évolue tous les jours
et quand il y a une bonne entente ça
passe vite
bien sûr
pourquoi pourquoi avoir choisi ce métier
c'est la question
je prenais les bouchons des radiateurs
un peu partout je me demandais comment
ça marchait pour poster là etc le plus
posé plein de questions puis après je me
suis renseigné aussi le salaire
les deux mois intéressés et c'était
compatible
le côté métier bien rémunéré et puis
le cap c'est vraiment que j'ai vu
comment le manuel était intéressant et
j'ai aimé faire ça c'est pas comment
dire mais
en fait une fois
qu'on a
[Musique]
il faut essayer pour savoir si le métier
fait quand même c'est pas facile à 15
saisons de dire je veux faire ce métier
là alors quand dans certaines familles à
un moment que les plombier mon
grand-père était menuisier on a
forcément un peu plus de facilité à
découvrir le métier à connaître le
métier en amont donc certaines familles
ou personne Emmanuelle c'est pas facile
de dire à 16 ans je veux faire menuisier
métallier donc faut essayer faut
découvrir ce l'avantage du BTP
au CFA de Brétigny c'est qu'on a
plusieurs corps de métier donc je
commence une formation
en CAP en métallerie c'est pas ça qui me
plaît je peux après faire un CAP en
menuiserie éventuellement ou à un moment
donné assez rapidement possible il est
possible de changer de de voix et de
filière certains jeunes sont dans des
entreprises coûtent que tout corps de
tout corps d'état donc c'est possible de
passer de la peinture à la menuiserie
éventuellement tout en restant dans la
même entreprise là où c'est compliqué
c'est quand il faut changer d'entreprise
j'en ai une je sais ce que j'ai c'est
pas forcément facile à retrouver une
deuxième mais aujourd'hui voilà un
métier peu importe le métier aujourd'hui
à 16 ans c'est pas facile de savoir ce
qu'on va faire dans la vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que tous les métiers
aujourd'hui du BTP sont quand même
assez bien rémunérés alors c'est un
métier lourd on reste pas dans un
mais on n'est pas derrière un bureau on
est assis c'est le métier assez physique
quand même mais voilà il y a quand même
des gros débouchés aujourd'hui et c'est
quand même très important de se dire à
la fin d'une formation peu importe c'est
un CAP et un BP ou un BTS je sais qu'à
la fin du diplôme peu importe le diplôme
que j'ai il y a de grandes chances que
je trouve une entreprise et que j'ai un
salaire donc aujourd'hui quand on sort
en fin de formation avec un métier entre
les mains un diplôme entre les mains et
une entreprise bah c'est tout gagné
faire des grandes études c'est très bien
ou des moins grandes études mais un bac
général aujourd'hui si je continue pas
en à la fac éventuellement des diplômes
super ça ne sert à rien c'est même plus
intéressant d'avoir et c'est pas
péjoratif d'avoir juste un cap parce que
j'ai un métier dans les mains et une
entreprise derrière
et sur ton pourra pas le remplacer par
des robots ou des machines aussi
mais pas totalement
vous aviez déjà répondu le salaire de
première année donc on avait dit dans
les 800 euros
alors il y a une question qui s'adresse
à vous aussi tous les trois
souhaitez-vous devenir chef d'entreprise
comme ça
effectivement
on sait que effectivement donc les chefs
d'entreprise installées pour à peu près
la moitié d'entre eux ils ont fait un
apprentissage ça c'est des statistiques
voilà après effectivement c'est pas
parce que j'ai une formation en
apprentissage que forcément je vais
devenir chef d'entreprise ça dépend de
nos envies ça dépend de vos moyens ça
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est tout à fait possible et qu'un des
débouchés effectivement de
métiers du bâtiment c'est
de devenir chef d'entreprise à son tour
sans que ce soit une obligation bien sûr
alors il y a une question sur les
Compagnons du Devoir qu'est-ce que vous
pouviez est-ce que vous connaissez enfin
j'imagine mais est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez dire des Compagnons du
Devoir c'est
différent parce que Compagnons du Devoir
tu es plus souvent
on est beaucoup de temps à l'école et
aussi beaucoup d'entreprises c'est pas
alterner donc ce n'est pas très école
c'est moi de moi en fait dans l'année
donc nous c'est vraiment une semaine une
semaine une semaine ça change c'est plus
regroupé en fait le temps de formation
et le temps de faire une grosse partie
enseignement théorique pratique mais
dans un centre mais après une grosse
partie où ils sont dans toute la France
sur différents métiers et on arrive
souvent aussi on se diversifie peut-être
un peu plus dans les Compagnons du
Devoir sur différents métiers même s'ils
ont une formation de base en menuiserie
en plomberie haute quand on arrive sur
les différents chantiers on s'aperçoit
vite qu'on dérive beaucoup sur
différents métiers
mais qui est complètement différente par
rapport à l'apprentissage on est
vraiment en entreprise rémunéré avec une
apparence une semaine sur deux ou une
semaine sur trois ça dépend des centres
c'est plus régulier c'est plus régulier
alors il y a une question sur les
compétences quelles sont les compétences
nécessaires pour faire votre métier
[Musique]
tout de suite
il faut arriver à 100 % c'est pas
possible tout de suite
être motivé
le matin et le travail
[Musique]
les potes et c'est pas très propre au
début on est un peu routissant par
rapport à ça au final en direct et c'est
bon
je parle pas de ça va être le mot de la
fin
c'est des métiers physiques bien évident
après en termes de compétences
techniques réellement ça s'acquiert au
fur et à mesure de la formation au fur
et à mesure des années mais voilà il
faut dès le début à la recherche
d'entreprise il faut être motivé sa
motivation tout le long de l'année tout
le long de la formation et même pour
plus tard après quand on va faire ce
métier là mais oui il faut
être gagnant vous êtes débrouillard faut
avoir faut avoir envie de travailler
pour certains dans le froid des fois
dans des positions des pas les plus à
adaptées et adéquates
faut être un minimum manuel quand même
voilà après en termes de connaissances à
s'acquiert avec
l'expérience
les compétences acquièrent
aussi travailler en équipe parce que
voilà quand on est sur des petits
chantiers un chantier individuel ou je
suis tout seul en train de travailler et
pas de souci mais il y a beaucoup de
chantier où on est multimédia
le petit intervenants il a pas fini là
elle va commencer il est pas là faut
pouvoir travailler en équipe c'est au
tour c'est mon tour faut pouvoir
dialoguer assez facilement alors quand
on en apprentissage bien évidemment tout
le temps avec son aide d'apprentissage
mais quand on est salarié dans une
entreprise il faut pouvoir continuer à
tailler avec les autres entreprises avec
les autres techniciens qui sont présents
et les clients et les clients aussi et
oui
est-ce qu'on a d'autres d'autres
questions visiblement vous avez posé
toutes vos questions vous en aurez
peut-être d'autres qui vont venir après
donc n'hésitez surtout pas à
pousser la porte du CFA parce que il y a
une soirée portes ouvertes le mercredi
15 février en soirée c'est 15h30 18h30
tu peux fin de fin de journée et puis
une autre le 25 mars en journée là de 9
heures à 16h30 donc le 25 mars c'est un
samedi et la soirée de l'orientation
c'est un mercredi
15 15h30 18h30 ou samedi 25 mars
9h à 16h30 donc n'hésitez pas aussi si
vous souhaitez découvrir un métier à
faire un stage comme je vous disais donc
il faut quand même que vous trouviez
l'entreprise mais on propose des
conventions qui peut vous permettre de
découvrir entre 1 et 5 jours le métier
donc pendant vos vacances scolaires
et puis on vous remercie beaucoup de
nous avoir écoutés et on vous dit à
bientôt au revoir au revoir